The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this is, as I
understand it, continuing the
conversation you've already
started on education.
And this is sort of the last
of the education lectures.
So what I propose to do today is
to just kind of try to tell
a story, a single story
that kind of fits some
of the facts together.
You've seen some of the broad
patterns of dysfunctionality
already, as well as some
of the local success
stories, if you like.
I think the last lecture was
about this NGO [INAUDIBLE]
and its many efforts to
improve education.
So what I'm going to do today
is continue from there, but
talk a little bit more
sort of big picture,
focusing mostly on--
the goal is to tie things
together into a story that
might make some sense, and help
us think forward about,
if this is what's going on,
where should we act?
That's always the ultimate
question we have in mind,
which is to try to find a way to
an action point or a lever.
And it's only by wrapping in
these facts into a narrative
that we can find a lever.
So what I want to do is
I want to go from
the fact to a lever.
And the way we will go there is
by talking about a specific
interpretation of the facts.
So that's what I want to do.
And I'm hoping that you already
read some of this
material and are sufficiently
engaged with it, that we'll
have a lot of discussion along
the way about, is this a
reasonable interpretation
of the facts or not?
And I'm very much open to the
idea that you may think that
this is not the right
interpretation.
And we can definitely, you
should feel free to propose
alternatives or whatever
you think.
You think I'm going too fast,
or trying to push the logic
too far, you should stop me,
or if you have questions.
So I think that the first fact,
which is I think very,
very widely accepted but somehow
not necessarily very
widely documented, is that
education is actually
beneficial for the people
who get it.
And you would that this is
something that we would have
seen tons and tons of reliable
evidence on.
But in fact, the reliable
evidence, even on this very
basic question, is
relatively weak.
The reason why education
evidence tends to be weak is
that, as you know, education's
not like taking a medicine.
The nice thing about
taking medicine is
that I take a medicine.
A week later, I'm better.
Education is something that
has action at a distance.
It's like something that I get
educated today and tomorrow
and day after, the
day after that.
And then distant future, I get
a job, and that's where it
benefits me.
So that sort remoteness of it is
actually part of the reason
why it's hard to find good
evidence for education.
You need to have a data set
where you saw who got educated
today, and what happened
to their
salaries' 20 years later.
And that's not always easy to
find, for obvious reasons.
You might imagine that
you do need to track
people in some way.
So that's why there's
not much evidence.
The evidence that there is, a
significant part of it comes
from countries like
the US, where the
evidence is very clear.
Education seems to have a clear
and relatively high,
stable rate of return.
Hasn't changed very
much over time.
And a few studies like the one
from Indonesia which also find
the same thing, and actually
find, surprisingly, relatively
similar rates of return
on education.
The benefits of education in
Indonesia seem to be similar
to that in the US.
And that's something that, when
it came out, was rather
surprising to people.
Why would it be surprising?
What would you have expected?
AUDIENCE: I don't know, that
education here might be better
or something.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you could imagine
that it would be--
education in the US has higher
quality, so maybe the returns
would be higher in the US.
Anybody want to suggest a
reason for the opposite?
AUDIENCE: Education in the
US is more expensive.
PROFESSOR: That's an
excellent point.
But primary education is what
we're talking about right now.
So that's not very
expensive, right?
It's mostly free.
AUDIENCE: If everyone in the
US has an education,
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
The opposite view is
that education
is scarce in Indonesia.
And especially in the early
'70s, very few people had
primary education.
So you might imagine that
something that's scarce
typically has a higher price.
So you might imagine that it
would be more rewarding.
So you could imagine it
going either way.
Turns out, these two effects
seem to have cancelled out.
And you get on net, roughly the
same rate on education in
the US as you get
in Indonesia.
But that's all to say that we
seem to think that there is--
it's not that there's a huge
amount of evidence.
But what there is seems pretty
consistent and compelling.
So I think most people accept
the idea that there is a
benefit from education.
And then the next question that
then arises is if there's
a benefit from education,
why are people
getting such lousy quality?
Why isn't it the case that
education systems kind of
stand up and deliver?
If education's valuable, why
isn't there a system that
supplies it?
Why is it that you have all
these schools where kids are
going and learning nothing?
AUDIENCE: Unlike other
investments, one is it's not
made by the primary
beneficiary.
I mean, parents that
fundamentally pay for the
investment or the government's
a case maybe.
And the parents paid the
lost wages that that
child could be earning.
The other thing that, unlike
other investments, is the
returns, like we talked about
earlier, are very long-term.
PROFESSOR: So you're saying that
one reason why education
might be different is the
connection between the cost
you're paying and the returns
you're getting is weak.
So maybe the government,
I don't really
think about the returns.
The government wants me to send
my children to school.
So I send them.
But I don't really
think about it.
So I don't think of
all the returns.
I don't make the investments
in it.
I don't really care about it.
It's just something the
government wants me to do.
And therefore, I don't
get benefits.
So I'm going to try to suggest
evidence that that's not
what's going on.
But that's exactly right.
One very plausible hypothesis is
that this is something that
people really, they're
not buying education
like they buy machines.
They're getting education
from the government
as a kind of gift.
And therefore, they don't
care about it.
So that's one kind
of explanation.
But that's exactly right.
That's one possibility.
Let's keep going a bit,
and we'll come--
go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, one of the
things that was written was
that they have this mistaken
impression that the first few
years of schooling have very low
returns and that secondary
education or university
education is where you
actually get a meaningful
increase.
So it gives the most incentive
to care about effective
education [INAUDIBLE] it's
someone they're planning on
funding later on.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And an alternative view, which
we'll come back to and spend
some time on, is that people
actually don't--
it's not that people don't
believe education's valuable.
They don't know which part
of education is valuable.
And that's sort of what
you're suggesting.
AUDIENCE: Question.
So we just talked about how,
in Indonesia, we saw there
were benefits to education.
And now we're talking about the
education being poor quality.
So is the idea that even this
poor quality education is
still incurring benefits that
people aren't realizing, that
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So I think that goes
back to the conversation
we had a little while ago, which
is that we would imagine
that in Indonesia, education
would be a lot more valuable
than in the US.
Because there's so
much less of it.
And you would think that when
I'm the first primary educated
person in the village, that's
much more valuable than being
the 2,000th.
Never the less, we don't find
high returns in Indonesia.
We find comparable to the US.
So the idea is, implicitly, that
the returns to education
are lower in Indonesia partly
because the quality is--
actually somebody suggested
exactly that, which is that
one reason why you might
expect lower returns in
Indonesia is that the
quality is lower.
And so I think the concern is
education is socially valuable.
We want it because there's
not many educated people.
On the other hand, maybe the
delivery systems are weak.
And therefore, it's not
worth getting it.
So that's a trade off.
And the question, if you look at
the other evidence, you've
already looked at it, it seems
like it's hard to imagine
somebody who's in fifth grade
and can't really read having
got much benefit
from education.
So our presumption is that at
least a significant proportion
of the people who are getting
to fifth grade without being
able to read are not getting
anything out of education.
They're just going through
the motions.
So why is it that there are so
many people who are going
through the motions rather than
saying look, why am I
wasting my time with this
education thing, unless it's
worth something to me?
That's sort of the question.
And a corollary to that question
comes from the fact
that, in fact, the Pratham
experience suggests, is it's
not even that hard to
improve quality.
It may well be that you could
imagine that it's just
impossible to improve quality,
because kids are very
difficult to teach.
But in fact, kids are not
The whole Pratham experience is
that whenever you have an
intervention which sort of
provides them with some little
bit of extra help and some
focused help on what they
need, the kids improve fast.
So that makes it even
more positing.
Because at some level, it's
easy to improve them.
The kids' education, if you've
got a high quality education,
that has value.
So what's going on?
Where's the pipeline broken?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] education
focused on all
levels of students,
[INAUDIBLE].
So it's not geared to
the basic needs that
each student needs?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think that that is part--
we're going to come and try to,
in a sense, develop that
hypothesis and look at how that
can help us explain a
whole bunch of different
things.
So that's exactly the kind of
hypothesis that we'll come to.
And it's good that we already
start hinting at it.
But I just want to first frame
the question quite sharply.
This seems like education is
something that, prima facie,
is valuable.
And it's not hard to deliver.
Those two things are
what you've seen.
You've seen that it
seems valuable.
It seems very low quality.
So many of you aren't getting
anything out of it.
And it's easy to make
sure that they get
something out of it.
Those three facts, how are
they sitting together?
That's the question.
You would think that one of
these facts has to give.
That's the puzzle.
Why is it that this thing that's
easy to improve is not
being improved, even though
improvements will generate
large gains.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's easy to
improve on a small scale, but
not so much on a large
and consistent scale.
PROFESSOR: That's another
possibility.
Now, part of the reason we
emphasize some of the Pratham
experience was that large
is a relative word.
But Pratham operates
on a fairly--
like a state in India is often
larger than any five countries
you would randomly name
in the world.
So it's not small in any
obvious scale of small.
That's why we were
emphasizing it.
So if you take five countries
at random, the sum of the
states, the way they work, would
be smaller than this.
Because India has
so many people.
OK.
So this is sort of the story
that several of you have
already hinted at, which is a
story that parents have the
wrong view of which part of
an education is valuable.
So starting point of
that is we call
it an illusory s-shape.
So you know the idea of
an s-shape, right?
The idea of an s-shape is that
when you get a little bit of
education that has very
little value.
And then as I get more and more
education, the value of
the education I'm getting
goes up for a while.
And then at some point,
presumably, it flattens off.
Once you've got your Ph.D.,
presumably a second Ph.D.
isn't worth that much, at
least in income terms.
So at some point, it's
going to flatten out.
So the returns go kind of like
that, then like that,
and then like that.
That's an s.
Is that clear, why it's an s?
So that idea.
One of the hypothesis that
I think we've been most
persuaded by is that parents
seem to believe that there is
a real jackpot if you
get to the end of
the education tunnel.
So they think of education
as being this tunnel.
Once you get into a tunnel,
there's nothing good happening
for a long time.
When you come out of the tunnel,
those who manage to
come out of the tunnel, which
means you get through the
whole school system and you
graduate from high school,
then you get a government
job automatically.
That's how they describe it.
70% of them think that if my
child could only get through
high school, he will actually
get a government job.
In fact, the probability that
he would actually get a
government job is less
than half of that.
So they seem to, at the
top end, they seem
to overvalue education.
They think that if my child
could only get through this
whole tunnel, there's a
job waiting for him.
But in fact, that's not true.
There are not enough government
jobs around.
So you don't get these
good jobs.
On the other end, and this is
the fact that's much harder to
appreciate, you will find out
what the probability of
getting a government job
is relatively easily.
But what's really hard to find
out is what are the benefits?
And especially if you are an
illiterate parent, what are
the benefits of getting three
years of education?
And if you think about it in
the US, the US actually,
nobody gets three years
of education.
Therefore, we can't even tell
what the benefits are.
But I think what is surprising,
but maybe not
surprising once you think about
it, is that the benefits
of people who get three years of
education's insubstantial.
Why are they substantial?
There are a bunch of stuff that
it's hard to appreciate
living from the perspective of
living in the US now, but are
not automatic.
So for example, many people
don't find out about
government programs that are
available to help them.
Why?
Because we don't read any
newspapers or flyers or when
the TV person say something,
they don't understand what is
being said.
So even a minimal understanding
of just how the
system works actually gets
you large benefits.
Or another example people often
give is that even if you
go from first grade to third
grade and you learn to read,
you can read the instructions
on your bag of fertilizer.
And your bag of fertilizer
says, use one
teaspoon, no more.
You know you're to use one
And put one cup of
water with it.
Just being able to read that has
a large benefit in a world
where people suddenly, lots of
evidence of people overusing
and underusing fertilizer.
So just the fact they can read
the instructions on the packet
is very, very large,
has large benefits.
So the reason why even getting
a third grade education has a
benefit is because there are
lots of things in the world,
lots of information that's
transmitted through reading,
for example.
Like what the government program
is, how to properly
use fertilizer, what new
seeds have become
available for planting.
And that might be in
the newspaper.
Somebody might have
taken an ad.
But you don't read the ad,
and you never find out.
So there are lots of benefits
even if you can read a little.
You don't have to be able to do
calculus to be able to get
benefits of education.
I think that's the evidence.
This picture that I'm going to
show you plots kind of actual
and perceived returns in
Madagascar to the extent that
they can be estimated.
The actual returns are
pretty constant.
The perceived returns come from
a survey where parents
were asked what the
returns were.
And the perceived returns
look more concave.
This is to say, they are more
flat in the beginning, lower
returns at the beginning.
The beginning, you think
that you're not
going to get much returns.
And then as you go
up, they get--
they cross, and you think you
are going to get more returns
than you actually get.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What that is is
really the percentage increase
in your earnings for an extra
year of education.
When you go to 11, to 12,
what's your percentage
increase in earnings?
So this in some sense
is actually not--
this picture sort of
gets the idea.
But in fact, it doesn't
actually tell you how
big the effect is.
The reason is that in fact,
there are some people who
generally overestimate the
benefits for education.
So some parents think
education's
extraordinary valuable.
And a lot of parents think that
education's completely useless.
So this yellow curve is
an average of very
lows and very highs.
So in some sense, the average
looks actually less wrong than
the individual parents think.
So some parents are
overestimating their returns.
They're all sending their
children to school.
Others just think education's
worthless, at
least for their children.
And their children is important
in that sentence,
because a lot of people think
education is something that
benefits those other children.
People from rich families can
benefit from education.
Our children don't benefit.
So there's clearly a strong kind
of self-discrimination,
which we'll come back
to in a bit.
So that average actually masks
a lot of divergence.
So what I want to do now is I'm
going to take this as a
hypothesis, the fact that this
what I would call elite bias,
the idea that people think
it's an s shape.
Returns are at the high end,
no returns at the low end.
Assume that that's true.
And look at how that can
help us explain a
bunch of other facts.
So we're going to look at what
this does for the parents, the
teachers, the students.
You see where we're going?
We're going to make
a hypothesis.
We've made the hypothesis.
Now we're going to look at what
that hypothesis does.
Particularly, you know a bunch
of facts, and we'll try to fit
together a bunch
of those facts.
Then at the end, I'll tell you
some other facts that you
probably don't know, which
also kind of fit this
hypothesis.
So it's sort of a way to
give it a bit more
power, if you like.
Try it out on things.
So one implication is think of
the first implication of this.
Imagine that, I believe that you
get benefits only if you
get through high school.
And you have three children.
And you can't really afford to
put all three of them through
high school.
So in truth, as we saw, the
returns are pretty constant.
So an extra year is
an extra year.
If it were the case that an
extra year, an extra year, how
should you spend the money?
Equally.
Since all the children,
there's no reason to
discriminate.
Why give one of them a chance
and not the others?
Any bias towards equity will
make you just spend equal
amounts over the children.
Because they're all
your children.
Why discriminate?
One year of education is
one year of education.
So there's no reason
to discriminate.
Now, imagine we believed
something else.
We believe that the
first years of
education are worth much.
But then the final years
are worth a lot.
How would we spend our money?
AUDIENCE: I'm assuming
you have two
kids who are identical.
You have [INAUDIBLE].
between the two.
And you believe that the latter
is the most important
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
You think of it as being--
you guess which of
your children
will be good at education.
And you're going to give all
your education to that child,
and give the other
one nothing.
That's one implication of this
view, is that you're going to
discriminate among
your children.
Now, the way you're going to
discriminate is probably, you
probably don't believe your
children are identical.
So you're going to
look for signs.
Maybe in first grade, one of the
children was doing better
than the other.
It means nothing.
Some children do well
in first grade.
Some children do badly
Many of you who are at MIT
were doing badly in first
grade, and then ended
up at MIT.
I'm sure some people
were doing very
well in first grade.
Didn't get to MIT.
So it's a very poor predictor.
Your first grade performance, a
very, very poor predictor of
your long term performance.
It's a predictor, but not
particularly a reliable one.
But parents, what do
they have to go on?
They're going to look at which
child is doing well in first
grade, and then put their
money on that one.
So you wouldn't probably
pick one at random.
But you pick one based on
some very noisy signal.
You observe whether they come
back from first grade with,
they chewed up their pencils
in first grade
more or less or something.
And you decide, well, this
one's fit for education.
This one's not.
And then you're going to
put your money on that.
You're going to find some way
of, since you can't spend
equal amounts on both, you're
going to find some signal
that's going to allow
you to discriminate.
Right?
That's what you'd expect.
So actually, let me go back one
slide and just talk about
discrimination a little bit more
before we get to this.
So this is something that
if you do field work in
developing countries, this
is something that
jumps out at you.
And something that you spend--
like me, I've spent all my
adult life in the US.
So I'm kind of used
to the US now.
So you go to somebody's house.
What's the chance you'll hear
a parent with two children,
one sitting here, the other
standing there, and he looks
at the child who's sitting there
and says, oh, that one,
he's an idiot.
He's not capable of
study, literally.
I don't mean metaphorically.
I mean literally, that
one's an idiot.
But this one, she's
really bright.
And you hear that
all the time.
It's something you'll never
hear in the US.
You'll never hear parents
actually pointing to one of
their children and saying,
this one's an idiot.
That comes very much out of this
theory that in a sense,
there are these, I have
the pick the winner.
The pressure on the parents
is to pick the winner.
Because if you don't pick the
winner, you wasted your money.
So they're trying to
pick the winner.
And in a sense, they are, in
fact, trying to persuade not
just themselves, but also the
siblings to go along with it.
And you see that very much.
I've also seen, which is even
more touching, is one child
saying, you ask him which
school you go to?
He says, oh, I go to
this school, but I
don't really go anymore.
And I said, why?
And he says, well, I'm stupid.
I can't do it.
But you know, my brother over
there, he's really smart.
He's going to the private
school, and
he's doing very well.
And so everybody in the system
internalizes it.
You see that very clear, every
word having internalized.
And that's useful
for the family.
Because the family doesn't want
to sustain a feeling of
inequality.
So if all children believe that
there's only one child
who is smart among them, then
it's good for the family.
The harmony in the
family remains.
Because all the other children
are willing to not be
educated, because they
think they are
not fit to be educated.
So everybody buys into
this idea that this
one child is bright.
And you see that all the time.
Just prima facie, you
see it all the time.
We'll also talk about
evidence.
But I also wanted to say that
that's the shape of it, is
often, you hear people pointing
to this child and
saying, that one is an idiot.
And that's very striking.
If you come to the US, you never
hear a parent say that.
And I don't think it comes out
of the fact that these are
worse parents.
They love their children.
They'll do lots for
their children.
But they really believe that
there is this sort of--
they need to be very good at
picking who's the winner.
Because they need to justify
that to themselves.
They need to justify that to
their other children, the fact
that they pick the
right winner.
That's very important to them.
And you see that very much.
So two studies.
One is in Burkina Faso, they
found that if conditional on
my cognitive score, in a simple
test score, if my
brother is doing well, I'm less
likely to be in school.
So if my brother's doing well,
or my sister's doing well,
that hurts my chances of
getting investment.
So that's exactly what
we're talking
about, picking winners.
Second, in Colombia,
they were given a
conditional cash transfer.
Conditional cash transfer is
like some money which you get
if you child is in school.
And the way it had been
implemented is that some
children were eligible for it.
So basically, when some children
were eligible for it,
parents decided, well, we'll
invest in this child.
That picked the child
to invest in.
That meant you stopped investing
in the other one.
The other child actually were
less likely to go to school,
if your brother was
encouraged by the
government to go to school.
So the government was actually
kind of focused on one child.
And you were getting some money
from sending one of the
children to school.
The other one was
then neglected.
And so you see exactly this
pattern of parents trying--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did they choose
the children to get the
investment?
PROFESSOR: In this particular
case, I think it was based on
some age rule.
I think only certain grades
were eligible,
if I remember right.
So it was like seventh graders
can get it, but sixth graders
can't, or something.
I think that was the rule.
It was an age rule, age or
I think maybe a class.
AUDIENCE: So they chose a class
at a particular level.
And then they continued
that class throughout.
PROFESSOR: Right.
I think that's right.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Well, I have two questions.
Does this pattern stay the
same if school is free?
If it's still one child
that goes to school?
And also, if it's conditional
cash transfer, wouldn't that
increase the income
to the family?
So they would have more
resources to spread around?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So both are excellent
questions.
I think yes, it's still
true where it's free.
Because one of the ways you
discriminate is by sending
your bright child to
private school.
You actually spend resources to
send him to private school.
Or you get him a tutor.
He gets special help.
Or he doesn't have to
do the housework.
He gets time to do his homework
in the evening, while
all the other children are
like tying up the goat or
whatever, giving food to
the cow, or whatever
else they are doing.
He's the one who gets
to do the homework.
So that's one sense in which
you still have lots of
discrimination.
And to answer your other
question, it's true that I
think that discrimination,
again, that's related.
The answer I just gave is also
relevant for that, which is
that part of the way to
operate is not just
discrimination in money spent,
it's also in time.
It's also in this, whose job
is to tie up the cow?
Whose job is to take care
of the younger siblings?
All of those get allocated
unequally.
So the child who gets to go to
private school typically is
also the one who doesn't
take care of the cow.
So you get loaded on
benefits from that.
Does that answer
your question?
OK.
So another implication of this
is that, this is a related
point, which is that parents
will often--
another implication of this is
that if people associate
education with particular forms
of getting a particular
job, then when there are more of
those jobs, they might now
start discriminating more
against the children.
Why?
Because now there is a valuable
opportunity available
for my daughter.
She can get this kind of job if
she only gets this degree.
And I'm going to now try to,
therefore, find resources to
make sure my daughter
can get that degree.
That might mean that I'm going
to give up on my son entirely.
So discrimination.
Another related consequence of
this is that when a particular
job appears which has high
returns, which you perceive
generates high returns for
education, you would target
money towards getting
that job.
And that would increase
this tendency toward
discrimination.
So there's an experiment in
India, a very nice experiment.
What this guy did is
there are all these
call centers in India.
You must have dealt with one.
If you've ever had to call
United Airlines, for example.
One of the things I love about
this is once they hear my
name, their accent
quickly changes.
And they stop trying to fake
an American accent.
They figure that I don't
care so much.
But so these call centers are
in this part of North India
where this is actually
huge discrimination
against girls, otherwise.
But what he did in this
experiment is he went to these
villages near the call center
and said, well, there's a call
center right there.
And if your daughter graduates
high school, she
can get a job there.
So that was the experiment.
And he went and told--
and you immediately find parents
suddenly starting to
discriminate against
their sons.
They start to figure out,
my daughter can
get this good job.
Now I should just put all the
money in her education.
And what happens to my son
doesn't matter anymore.
So you get this pattern of once
parents decide that there
is a jackpot to be had, it's
very easy to get into these
patterns of massive
discrimination within the family.
So in particular, girls'
education went up?
Why?
Because call centers
like girls.
Apparently, the view is, may
or may not be true, is that
girls are easier to train to
be call center employees.
They're more docile,
more, I don't know.
They learn English faster.
There are all kinds
of theories.
But in any case, call centers
like girls, for some
unspecified reason.
So they found out that there
was a big demand for girls.
The result was that you get
this effect on boys.
On net, boys were
not affected.
But parents already, the
baseline had said, this son,
he's not really fit
for education.
So those kids are really got
hurt when this happened.
Because all of those kids who
the parents had decided were
not fit for education, their
education actually dropped
when their sisters started
getting these jobs.
You started substituting away
from their education towards
less education for them.
So this is all to say that
parents are actually using all
these cues to figure out which
child to put the money on.
Because they believe that if I
put money on one child, I'll
get much bigger benefits than
sharing it across children.
And then all these cues
seem to matter.
OK, let's go back to
a different fact.
Another thing that of
course matters is
information in this world.
For parents, what matters is
their perceived returns.
That's what we're talking.
We're talking about
perceived returns.
We're talking about the fact
that parents think their
returns are higher when you get
12th grade education, and
low if you get less than 12th
grade education, et cetera.
So Madagascar, parents were
shown this particular picture.
This picture's kind of
a way to capture
the returns to education.
So without any degree, you
get three kg of grain.
If you get a few more
years, you get four.
If you get more, you get
seven, et cetera.
So this was roughly
the right scaling.
So this is roughly how the
returns are in Madagascar.
AUDIENCE: Is it [INAUDIBLE]
the political [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's the range.
For females, it goes
from 34 to 163.
For men, from 47 to 225.
So this was what they
were shown.
When they were shown this,
turned out-- so actually,
before they did that, they
actually asked parents, what
do you think are the returns
to education?
Before they showed them, they
actually asked them, if your
child got an education,
how much would his
income go up by?
So they had written that down.
Then they showed them
this picture.
And what's nice is that the
parents who already thought
that children were going to
get high returns, their
behavior didn't change
very much.
Whose behavior has changed?
The parents who thought that the
returns for the children
were much lower than
they really are.
And about 50% of the parents
had very low returns.
And for those parents,
you get a very
substantial improvement in--
no, that's not it.
I don't know where--
OK.
So it was a very substantial
improvement in the children's
school attendance, to the point
where every intervention
we have studied, the cheapest
way to improve school
attendance that we found,
ever, is this one.
This really is an
extraordinarily cheap
intervention.
It doesn't cost much money to
tell people the returns on
education are higher
than you think.
If you can do it in a credible
way, that improves education
very cheaply.
And it has a substantial
effect.
This turns out to be the
cheapest single thing that
Poverty Action's lab researchers
found for
improving education.
Obviously, it doesn't
do everything.
You can't go very
far with this.
Because it's not going
to distill all
kinds of other things.
If the education system's
broken, then people are not
going to learn anything from
the school, et cetera.
But to get them into school,
this is a very, very
cheap way to do it.
So there's lots of parents who
are clearly discriminating
against their children and not
sending them to school because
they think their children
are not going to get
anything out of it.
Why do they think that?
Well, they think that their
children are never going to
make it through the 12th grade,
or whatever it takes to
get real money from education.
So they'll already assume that,
my child is never going
to make it 12th grade.
Since he's never going
to make it to 12th
grade, what's the point?
And therefore, they don't
send children to school.
You persuade them that even if
you went from third grade to
fifth grade you get extra
returns, then they start
sending children to school.
So the returns to primary
education for many, many
parents are massively
underestimated.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a
quick question.
Is it distributed evenly across
the incoming classes?
So for example, you were trying
to say education was
for people who are
very wealthy.
It could be 120% returns to
people-- it's education to
people who are lower class to
be 0.5%, in which case, that
progression will be tilted
towards the high end.
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So people have looked at that.
Typically, it's difficult
to look at.
Because you could imagine that
very few people who are
wealthy families stop
at third grade.
But to the extent that you can
look at it, you don't see big
differences.
There's some differences, but
not of the order of magnitude
you're suggesting.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if anyone has
looked at the peer effects.
Like you have a village.
And there's several families.
And some of them are sending
their kids to school, and
others aren't.
Are there any effects that just
one family sees how the
other kids, look, they're
going to school.
And they seem to be learning.
And they seem to be
accomplishing something.
Do they feel like they're
just wasting their time?
Their parents always complain
[INAUDIBLE].
Are there any effects
between families?
PROFESSOR: Probably.
Nobody's looked.
I mean, people look at this.
But the problem is that when
you study peer effects, the
first problem is that typically,
your peers are not
randomly chosen.
So you hang out with families
that are like yours.
So therefore, the peer effects
tend to be over estimated.
What looked like peer effects
could be just the effect of,
who do you hang out with?
So there's lots of evidence of
peer effects, but not so much
at this level.
Because it's hard to randomly
assign peers.
The one place where you can
randomly assign peers turns
out to be in college.
So there is a nice set of
studies, like of Dartmouth,
for example.
In Dartmouth, there's
a college lottery.
And you get different roommates
based on your lottery.
So if you get roommates who are
more inclined to study,
you're more inclined to study.
You get roommates who are more
inclined to drink, you are
more inclined to drink.
There seems to be clear
evidence of some
kinds of peer effects.
But it's hard to find because
of this reason.
If you look at the data,
it looks like
there's huge peer effects.
If you look in the US, and you
look around Boston, you'll
find that in Somerville, people
who live in Somerville
seem to live with other
people who don't
get much of an education.
And people that live in
Lexington live with other
people that get a lot
of education.
That's not because of
large peer effects.
It's because people who want
to get a lot of education,
good education, go to
live in Lexington.
Or other characteristics of
people who live in Lexington,
rich people live in Lexington.
It's not because of peer.
So peer effects are
hard to detect.
But I think that where people
have tried to look at it, like
with this Dartmouth lotteries
and stuff, they find it.
But it's hard to detect for the
reason we just discussed.
OK.
So now what I want to do is
switch to the teachers.
So we talked about the effect
of this on the parents.
The parents do two things.
One is that they don't invest
in most of their children.
I'll come back to the parents,
actually, later.
And the second is that
they discriminate.
Let's go to the teachers.
Same hypothesis.
Teachers also believe, and
maybe teachers don't
intrinsically have to believe
this, if parents believe that
the only goal of the school is
to get their children to 12th
grade or whatever to get through
school, then teachers
will have the same incentives.
So the teachers will believe
what the parents believe.
Because it doesn't matter
what the truth is.
I'm going to get paid if
the parents like me.
And the parents like
me if I have the
belief that they have.
So it's not clear that the
teachers even need to have the
wrong beliefs.
But I suspect parents,
teachers do
have the wrong belief.
I'll tell you why
in a little bit.
So first thing that that implies
is that teachers will
teach to the top of the class.
If you believe that the goal of
this whole thing is to get
children to complete 12th grade,
and in addition, you
believe that you live in a
country where most people
don't complete 12th grade,
then you're going to say,
well, most people are
not capable of
completing 12th grade.
Because in fact, that's
what you see.
Only 20% complete 12th grade.
In Madagascar, maybe 10%
complete 12th grade.
And you see that, you say that
most people are not going to
complete 12th grade.
So therefore, doesn't make any
sense to try to get the bottom
of the class to--
if I believe A, that completing
12th grade is the
only thing that I care about,
and B, that only a small
fraction of these kids are
capable of reaching 12th
grade, I think both of which
are probably false, but
imagine I believe those
two things.
How should I teach?
I'll teach to the top
of the class.
Because those are the
only people who are
going to make it.
So I might as well concentrate
my resources on that, and
forget about the rest.
The rest are here
as passengers.
They're going to come.
They're going to listen.
They won't get anything.
They'll leave.
I don't really care, because
that's not the goal.
And in particular, there's
a nice instance of this.
I'll talk about an experiment
in a little bit where the
school got an extra teacher,
let's say for eighth grade, or
fourth grade.
And in fourth grade, this
class was split up.
And half the class was given
to the extra teacher.
to the original teacher.
In some of the schools, it was
done so that the better
performing children went to
one teacher, and the worst
performing children go
to the other teacher.
This was done by lottery.
So there was a lottery.
And one teacher got one, and
the other got the other.
The teacher who got the
bottom half of the
class was really upset.
Because they really believe
this is pointless.
They thought that this was just,
why am I teaching the
bottom half of the class?
There's no point in
teaching them.
Because they, too, believe that
the bottom of the class
can't learn.
Because their whole goal is not
to get them from fourth
grade to fifth grade, but to get
them from fourth grade to
12th grade.
So the goal of teaching, it's
pointless to teach people at
the bottom of the class.
Because people at the bottom
of the class can't learn.
So once you believe that people
at the bottom of the
class can't learn, then you
focus your effort at the top
of the class.
Now as you can imagine, what is
the consequence of that on
the students?
What would that do to students
at the bottom of the class?
AUDIENCE: Well, they were
probably discouraged.
They'd feel more discouraging if
the teacher is actively or
subconsciously [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Is that what you were
going to say?
Yeah.
So they're going to
get discouraged.
Now what happens when they
get discouraged?
AUDIENCE: Poor performance.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I said poor
performance.
PROFESSOR: They perform
poorly.
What does the teacher think?
AUDIENCE: Stupid.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
they're stupid.
So it's a vicious cycle.
Because once I believe the start
from this theory, that
the bottom of the class
can't perform, then I
give them no attention.
They're all discouraged.
They're not trying.
They're doing badly.
I think they're stupid.
Then I feel like, you know, I
was right in focusing on the
top of the class.
So you get into this vicious
cycle of false beliefs.
The other thing that this would
mean is that teachers
also really--
so teachers also, in class, they
will look for the kids
who can get to their view of
whatever the goal is, getting
through high school.
And if there are a few kids like
that in high school in
this class, they're going to
stop putting in effort.
You also expect why teachers
would not put in a lot of
effort, because they'll think,
look, I got stuck with a bunch
of dodos who can't learn.
What am I doing here?
So once teachers start believing
that children are
unequal, then you get this
phenomenon that lots of
teachers also give up.
So the Pratham experience is,
I think, illuminating here.
So one of the experiments you
must have talked about was the
summer school experiment.
The summer school was basically,
some villages
randomly got a summer school.
The teacher was given
some extra money to
run a summer school.
This is the same teacher who
teaches in school where the
schools are very
low performing.
Yet, when this teacher was given
a small amount of money
and was asked to run a six weeks
summer school after a
few days of training, that had
very large effects on the
children's learning.
The children who went to summer
school learned a lot.
So why is it that this teacher
who can teach these children
quite effectively in summer
school, why doesn't he teach
them effectively during
the school year?
What's going on?
How can it be that the same
teacher, when he teaches
summer school, he gets
large gains.
But when he teaches regular
school, he does so badly?
And one explanation is that in
summer school, his job is to
attend to the worst performing
children.
In the regular school, his
perception is that his job is
to attend to the top
of the class.
So in the regular year.
he's not teaching
these children.
He's teaching the top
of the class.
When he's actually told, teach
these children, he actually
can do it just fine.
It's just that's not what the
system is telling him.
His view of what his job is is
that I have to get the top of
the class to learn the entire
curriculum, and be able to get
into whatever, into a better
high school or something.
He doesn't see his goal
as teaching the
bottom of the class.
When you actually ask him to
teach the bottom of the class,
when that is his assigned
job, he does just fine.
So that would also be consistent
with this view that
the real problem is not that
the teachers don't have the
incentive to teach, or they
don't want to teach.
But they're being told to
teach the wrong thing.
They're trying to teach these
children something that
actually isn't.
So here's the experiment
I talked about.
This is very much
on this point.
I already talked about this
experiment, 120 schools were
cut into two, in 60 schools.
All schools were given
extra teachers.
And then half of those schools,
the extra teacher was
assigned to, the class
was split at random.
So every class, they used
to have one teacher.
Now they have two teachers.
Class was split at random.
So half the class went to one,
half went to the other.
In the other half of the
schools, they were
not split at random.
They were split by baseline
competency.
So the better performing
children
were sent to one teacher.
The worst performing
children were sent
to the other teacher.
The teacher assigned
was random.
So you didn't get a better
teacher or a worst teacher,
but you got to be in
a classroom with
children like you.
What would our theory say about
what's going to happen?
If you have any of the
top, what would
happen in this setting?
AUDIENCE: In both situations,
you teach to the top.
What it means for the teacher in
the randomly assigned room
is that the people who were
respectively at the top of the
class one, they still
get taught to.
But it means the people, when
it's divided into the high
performer, low performer, is
you teach the top of that
little [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So what this does is, I always
wanted to teach the best four
people only in the classroom.
But the best people in the
classroom have changed.
When I divide the classroom in
this way, the best people in
the low classroom is someone who
would have never got any
attention in the original
classroom.
Or if it was divided
at random, he would
never be at the top.
So it changes who
gets attention.
Moreover, because I'm now paying
attention to somebody
who's not at the top of the
class but in the middle of the
class, the children who are at
the bottom of the class are
more likely to get something
out of the class.
Because what happens is that
the distance between--
imagine that this is a class
which has me and someone else.
And I can't really read.
And somebody else can
read Shakespeare.
Now, if you teach to
the top of the
class, I'll get nothing.
But if I'm put it in the
classroom with somebody who
can read a little better
than me, but not that
much better, then.
If you teach to him, I'll still
get something out of it
because I'm closer to him.
AUDIENCE: Do the teachers
know something?
That they've got better--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's why they were
protesting.
And I said this before.
They were actually protesting.
But once they found out, they
decided fine, we'll teach the
best of this class.
But the best of this class is
still much less different from
the worst of this class, then
the difference between the
best and the worst in
the original class.
So even the worst in this class
gets something out of
the teaching, where you would
have got nothing before.
AUDIENCE: So do you think that
it'd be more effective to try
to re-educate teachers such
that they don't have the
attitude that they only teach
to the top of the class?
Or is it better just to accept
that as a reality, sort of
like in this survey.
And then just trying to make
some circumstance to get a
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's an
excellent question.
I guess my view is that it's
difficult to get the teachers
to believe that they should have
a different attitude as
long as parents have
that attitude.
So you need to start
with the parents.
Because after all, the
demand for education
comes from the parents.
So the parents are
the ones who are
demanding this education.
So in other words, to go back
to where we started, in this
view, what's wrong with the
school system is that the
parents think that there's no
point in educating their
children unless the children
are good enough to graduate
high school.
Therefore, they want the entire
education system to
focus on the few people in the
classroom who are high
performing, and ignore
the rest.
If that's what the parents
want, the teachers will
deliver that.
And it's going to get
too hard to get them
to do anything else.
You'll first have to start with
persuading parents that
even if their child is not going
to get to high school,
he still should be educated.
I think that's sort of
the, I think, this--
so in fact, that's exactly
what they found.
They found that when you do
this, when you divide this
class up, everybody benefits.
The top children benefit.
Because they're now
being taught.
The teacher is focusing
on them.
The top children of the bottom
class benefit, because the
teacher is benefiting
from them.
The bottom children of the top
class benefit, because they
are now closer to the top
of their own classroom.
And the bottom children in the
bottom class benefit because
they are closer to the top
of their classroom.
So everybody is better
off in this outcome.
Because as long as you can't
force the teachers to teach
the bottom, then what you can
do, next best thing, is to
bring the bottom closer
to the top.
And this is what this does.
If teachers are going to teach
to the top, then you should
try to have classrooms
where the bottom is
close to the stop.
And that's what you see.
The evidence is very clear,
everyone benefits from
creating these tracks.
This is the table.
I won't go through it.
Because we're going to
run out of time.
This has already we've said.
Who else gets hurt by this is
the children, obviously.
The children get hurt because
they get discouraged.
Most children get discouraged.
Because they think education
is not for them.
And this is especially true in
historically discriminated
populations.
So historically the
discriminated populations in
many countries tend to be either
by race or in India,
it's by caste, or girls,
depending on the particular
structure of discrimination.
Historically, discriminated
populations tend to already
assume that since they have very
few people who have been
educated, they assume that
that's perhaps because they
have no talent for it.
And then if you go and
tell them, look.
So another way to put it is that
if you happen to be from
a family who believe that you
can be educated, then if the
teacher says, you're stupid,
they won't believe it.
They're going to go and argue
with the teacher.
And say, look, in my family,
everybody has a Ph.D. What do
you mean, my son is stupid?
Whereas if you're actually from
a family where no one has
an education, it's much easier
to persuade them that their
child is not fit
for education.
So what you're going to do is
you're going to reinforce
stereotypes in society.
Because who's going to believe
you when you say
your child is stupid?
It's going to be the people
who have been told
historically that they're
not fit for education.
They're going to be the most
likely to believe you.
So this kind of stereotype, the
existing stereotype will
be reinforced by, if you give
people the message that their
child is stupid, the existing
stereotype would get
reinforced.
So that's something that
you see a lot.
You see that the parents in
these kind of very poor
families tend to be more
likely to believe these
negative stereotypes
of their children.
Another thing that this would
explain is why children don't
come to school.
One thing that people don't
emphasize is how rarely
children show up in school.
A lot of children basically
completely don't believe that
school is for them.
And they may be enrolled
in school.
So on a given day, up to 50% of
the children don't show up
in a class.
Now, that's also true at MIT, as
it turns out, but probably
not for the same reasons.
But many of these children
basically
hate being in school.
And they hate being in school
for the right reason, which is
that they're constantly being
told that this is not for you.
One interesting additional fact
that was, this goes back
to the stereotype, this
is a nice experiment.
So children were asked
to solve mazes.
You know what mazes are?
Like these things where you
have to draw a line, and
there's a point of entry
and a point of exit.
And you have to find
your way out of it.
So they were given these mazes
and asked to solve them.
I've done this, actually.
It's fun to do.
You can take a bunch of sheets
and get people in the village
to give their kids, and get
them to solve them.
And it's a very good
test of cognitive
abilities, it turns out.
So that's what people
usually do.
Now, somebody has a good idea
of trying to follow it.
They went to a village in India,
and they got together a
group of historically low caste
people, people who were
discriminated against.
And combined them with people
from high castes, and put them
in the same group.
And one experiment, they just
asked them, play the maze.
Do the maze.
And they found no difference
between high
caste and low caste.
They got the exactly
same scores.
Not everybody didn't get the
same score, obviously, but on
average, there was
no difference.
Second experiment, before they
play the game, everybody was
asked their caste.
So caste was made salient.
And immediately, you see
a big difference.
You see that the people
who were historically
discriminated self-discriminate.
They start playing badly.
They believe that they can't
compete with the other guys.
And they do much worse.
So once you make caste salient,
it's exactly this
fact that once you prime my
belief that I already am
unsure whether I can do these
things, you prime my belief
that I am from a particular
caste.
I'm playing against these guys
from a superior caste.
I'm just going to think
I'm going to lose.
And it's very simple.
You just have to get them to
remember what their caste is.
And there's another experiment
which is also interesting.
I'll just say that
and then move on.
In another experiment, teachers
were asked to grade
the same paper.
And in some, they were told that
the paper was from a high
caste person.
And some, they were told that
the same paper was from a low
caste person.
Same paper, exact same paper,
photo copy of the same thing
with the same answers, but
you're asked to grade it.
And in one case, I said, this
is from Caste A, the other
case, I say it's from Caste B.
That was the experiment.
Then the teachers themselves,
some of them were from a high
caste, and some of them
were low caste.
Who do you think
discriminated?
What was the pattern
of discrimination?
AUDIENCE: I'm guessing the
high class discriminated
against the low class.
PROFESSOR: Turns out
the opposite.
The low class discriminated
against the low class.
Low class were scoring their
own caste people lower.
Because they also believe
that people from their
caste cannot do it.
So you have this underlying
stereotype.
And now you prime that by
saying, this kid is stupid.
What are they going to do?
They're going to give
up very quickly.
As they already believe that
they are not really
capable of doing it.
AUDIENCE: In the maze
experiment, did the results
from the high caste
[INAUDIBLE]
change [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I think they went
down, if I remember correctly.
They went down, but the
others went down.
AUDIENCE: In the grade paper
example, did the high caste
graders discriminate also
against the low caste?
PROFESSOR: No.
No discrimination from
the high caste.
Only the low caste--
AUDIENCE: Did they grade the
high caste papers any higher?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Zero effect
of the high caste.
Only the low caste teachers
discriminated against the low
caste students.
It was dramatically--
it's not what I expected.
But it does show this
self-discrimination is very powerful.
The reason I emphasize that is
that that's the problem here.
Once I have a classroom full
of kids who are being told
they're stupid, the ones who
are from a high caste are
going to say, look, I know my
grandfather was a religious
teacher, and my father's
a religious teacher.
I know I am fit for education.
I'm going to continue.
It's the people who have weak
self-belief who are going to
be hurt by a system which
basically discriminates
against them.